first of all congratulations on um the
cmg situation
um
i feel like uh you have been kind of
like our our uh champion here on the
west coast
in terms of just like who i feel like
you know if i had to bet all the all the
[ __ ] money push it in on the middle
of the table it'd be on you for a long
time man so it's good to see um
i guess like the rest of the industry
kind of catch on if that makes sense it
is a little tardy we ain't worried about
it though we most definitely i'm saying
i ain't gonna lie like just this whole
experience you know this is my first
time i mean signing or even going in
that direction i've been independent to
the necklace
uh and so i just wanted to see what this
machine do so i'm excited to see what it
do yeah for you like um like you said
you've been in indy for so long um
what were the things that were important
for you to like finally
cross the other side of the aisle and
and and go the major route uh first and
foremost i wanted to establish like a
catalog i wanted catalog i wanted to be
you know i wanted to own my own catalog
before i
crossed over
and um
i wanted to make sure i was fine
financially legitimate right i didn't
want to go over there and then you know
next thing you know i got all type of
complaints because i feel like you know
i ain't received a check in
some odd months or you feel me i'm just
you know this just discomfort i wanted
to be comfortable when i when i finally
made my move uh shut out the net you
know just following his marathon
and uh his outlook on this whole thing
but uh yeah i just wanted to be
comfortable and i wanted to you know i
ain't wanted to i didn't want to be
forced and i wanted to have a little
leverage i wanted to be able to um yeah
kind of customize my deal and uh make
sure it made sense yeah because i think
most artists they sign too soon and then
they end up complaining on instagram
about the record lane
come on
so for sure
um how long like how long has it been
since gotti like originally reached out
we've been [ __ ] around ain't [ __ ]
around bobby brown uh you know we didn't
have and sat down on multiple occasions
um
i'm talking about years back
and uh like i said i just wasn't
comfortable at the time i was really
i was ecstatic at the way that my career
was going you know independent route for
me to be able to i'm seeing me really
log in and see my numbers
um that empire back-end is nice you get
to log in yeah yeah receiving the
monthly checks
um and just feeling like i had control
of my own career so uh that was dope but
i just feel like right now is the time
right now is the time i want that
injection i want that little power boost
have you noticed um maybe like
people who maybe weren't embracing you
before kind of come around now that you
got you know that i mean because looks
and if we're being honest god you've got
the hottest label in the game right now
i don't think anybody would dispute that
um the team is crazy i ain't really
noticed a lot um because everybody being
genuinely functioning with me so uh it
ain't too many people like jumping on
the bandwagon or nothing like that
uh
and then you know i ain't i ain't really
been traveling lately to where i can see
i'm seeing a difference right right
right right media going to different
[ __ ] right right right so uh it's been
everything as you know as it's been as
is um
but uh
i've been getting a lot of
congratulations a lot of congratulations
everywhere i go congratulations
congratulations congratulations and um
so you know that alone let me know that
that was a good move on my behalf
and um i'm just excited i'm excited to
drop the album see what it does
and just establishing this relationship
continue to build i'm saying put the
pieces together and uh press play